oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect
yo
what's up guys i am thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me this is
marty o'neil drastic what's up this is
the dope usual podcast welcome back to
another episode we are here to talk
about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between
season two soul episode number two marty
how do you feel
boom
[Music]
that's how i [ __ ] feel let's go you
had it
you got some new sound effects going
yeah
all right
that made me happy man i didn't know
that you had those yet
yo that was sick
that's what we need just that one yeah
crisp one guys uh
what's up i haven't seen you guys in so
long it's been over a month
going on five weeks since i've been
right here with marty just talking to
you guys hi hello hello your friend over
there your friend over there how you
guys doing hanging out in the garage in
the living room in the car at work in
the bathroom like
like this wherever you're watching from
thank you so much for watching guys uh
this is season two all right this is
season two
we've had a lot of guests back to back
to [ __ ] back and uh let's talk about
it we haven't seen you guys since
episode one episode one holy [ __ ] of
season two so you know let's go over a
little bit all right episode one went
[ __ ] awesome super stoked to have
season two new set no planes no care
packages no cricket crazy no cricket i
haven't heard one thing i went back and
listened to that goddamn emoji episode
that thing was [ __ ] crooked oh man it
was god it was going hard
um
so
next guest we had first guest we had of
the season snack bundle spencer let's go
you guys i'm gonna say it now every time
we have lower views on an episode it's
one of my favorites um how does that
always happen i don't know it always
resonates with me harder and i go
i thought it would explode i thought
people would love this and it's not
saying people didn't i'm saying i don't
think it's gotten out there because
sometimes you might bring in somebody
that you know is going to be an amazing
conversation that maybe a lot of people
don't know might not be super [ __ ]
like and i had never met him before that
day yeah exactly
yeah snack bundles episode go back and
watch that [ __ ] it was great would you
change it to the canadian connection
probably
either way hustle continue the hustle
continues watch that episode
very [ __ ] inspirational
they are crushing it out there in canada
all right i don't want to say too much
if you have time go back and watch the
hustle continues right is that what's
called the hustle continues episode
that's episode two season two
great [ __ ] episode
super super good episode
all right and thank you guys for [ __ ]
supporting him just inadvertently they
had their most orders to the us ever
after
the week after our episode first most
orders to us of all time you guys are
all [ __ ] cool also where else are you
going to find some crazy ass candies and
so this is not it's like the best
christmas present it truly is like a box
of exotics [ __ ] dunk oh my god
i wish i could eat that [ __ ] but i'm
glad i can't because i would be smashing
all of it just full diabetic coma i am
[ __ ] i
sugar is addicting for sure i've been on
the bench me too
i ate gummy worms at two in the morning
last night woke up and went gummy worms
don't go to sleep after you eat bad
candy anyway
uh the hustle continues go watch the
episode the next one after that is
kidnapped and on the run with ida
rodriguez guys i have a lot of people no
no the next one was steve oh oh my god
it was switched we filmed these so close
together yeah
sorry because i was getting in the
steevo next that's right we switched
those
sorry we filmed two in one week
that's what [ __ ] [ __ ] me up we haven't
been filming for over a week and a half
yeah sorry let me get into the very next
one we're gonna die after because we'll
go in order the next one was [ __ ]
stevo and you guys if you haven't
watched that you're [ __ ] up go watch
the stevo episode that man is so much
more intellectual than i thought he was
gonna be he was so much more on a deeper
thinking tip than just like you'll light
me on fire and [ __ ] on me
there was so much more man he really did
i i really liked it and the thing that
i don't want to ruin anything if you
just go watch the episode it's if you
like jackass and you like stuff i like
go watch the episode that to me made my
sixth grade me go
yeah i don't know i was worried the [ __ ]
is happening because i remember like i
said i told him like i remember the day
it came out
i remember going to school and everyone
just did you see that [ __ ] did you see
that guy do it back he ate a goldfish
like what
yeah so that one to me was like
good [ __ ] so anyway stevo was here super
cool and by the way everybody when you
see those new goddamn apparel lines
that's what i was going to bring up oh
okay that's exactly what's going to
bring up i need to give steve shout out
to stevo
one of the only people i have ever met
in my life besides marty to say they're
going to do something and then start
doing it right then and there i love it
so much i love when people are on the
ball we were talking tom about our
uh could we we were printing with some
not push trees dope as usual products
were printing with some company
they just [ __ ] suck on top of dick
they don't give a [ __ ] about money they
[ __ ] suck
they're super late anyway stevo was like
you have a problem let me talk to my guy
he got on the phone with his [ __ ]
manufacturer right in front of us
in our parking lot did everything got a
meeting with them the very next week
already had the meeting already started
everything now we're just waiting to
start up the close guys dope as usual
merch
is not just merch
dope as usual clothing is going to be
its own line the [ __ ] we got coming out
is moral on the top on the line of like
a brand yeah i can see that [ __ ] of
zoomies yeah oh [ __ ] that's tight that's
what we're going for i mean just walking
through their facility seeing who they
[ __ ] with is like everyone could say
everybody's but some of the biggest
rappers in the world are right there i'm
like wow you guys are [ __ ] this [ __ ]
was inspiring homeboy looked like he
could be my [ __ ] brother too oh for
sure
[ __ ] gigantic man he was very cool in
there they were on point and it turns
out he's childhood friends with my good
friend shane that makes all my breaks in
all my classes childhood friends with a
guy
couldn't have worked out better man but
we're going to really really like amp it
up roll it out like a real brand oh yeah
we got a lot of clothes the freddy
krueger hitting the meth pipe is already
on the template don't worry guys we're
going to have freddy krueger hitting the
mat pipe soon and we're going to be able
to do [ __ ] like that quick yeah when
something funny happens
so guys dope as usual clothing apparel
everything is coming soon by the end of
the year we're going to have a full
collection and then we're just going to
start going our first line was cool it's
great i love this first one it's great i
almost wore it i'm so glad i didn't i
almost wore that today mm-hmm would it
look like i love our [ __ ] but we just
needed to go we just need to go up
levels yeah just go better higher faster
fulfillment yeah send our stuff off when
people buy it not eight days later i
hate it
anyway
steve oh shout out to you for helping us
step our stuff up right and something
very cool i texted him a couple days
later and he's like bro she's in the
live chat for an hour and a half so
stevo did take our advice and now he's
in the live chat on youtube so every
time stephen drops a podcast go on the
live chat and steve was in there typing
two jobs that's the other thing i loved
about him he's like he wasn't too cool
to be like oh guys that's a great idea
not at all not at all he's like is that
work i'm gonna try it you try to the
next [ __ ] day yeah so i appreciate it
i've been watching his story he's going
crazy on that [ __ ] tour what's it
what's it called what's it called
the newest tour i think it's like gnarly
some shot frog i can't remember i'm so
sorry but
stevo's newest uh tour is
going nuts every one of us in the
theater they're all sold out yeah i've
been seeing his stories every selling
out everything so shout out to steve
speaking
man i was at the [ __ ] spectrum last
night felipe had the goddamn line around
the [ __ ] corner oh he played this
spectrum fleet baseball it was his third
night there still the thing was that
night yes around the [ __ ] corner like
deep down around the corner down the
[ __ ] street he's hilarious yeah he's
[ __ ] funny man speaking of him i just
went on this podcast what's up fool go
check it out there's an episode with me
on there we just talk about fat guy
stuff pretty much
we talk about fat oh man when i rolled
down when i saw that [ __ ] line i
realized it was felipe i started man i
got the [ __ ] butterflies like yep
soon
yeah for real
um
a spectrum yeah spectrum
i forgot about the
comedy store the live factory
um oh [ __ ] sorry sorry off topic my bad
thank you so much stevo you're the
[ __ ] man steve was in his live chats
now so go on youtube check that out
sorry how long are we in time
ten minutes ten minutes okay i'm not
gonna let the joint i wanna get through
my uh [ __ ] talking point real
quick sorry for taking so long very next
guest we had after stevo ada rodriguez
and like i said every time those views
are lower
it's one of my favorite conversations i
i don't know why it always works out
that way anyway ada rodriguez is a
stand-up comedian
she's
she's on the level of speaking
intellectually that i need to be
in order to hold and like further
conversations that just don't mean
but i love that about me because that's
how i feel like [ __ ]
or i could say that is a crazy
observation or that is insane
wow astute
i'm glad you took so many years to learn
this [ __ ] so it can bounce off me
thank you for taking the time to you
know further your education [ __ ] bro
[Laughter]
but i love the conversation she was
she put me on to knowledge right then
and there which is very very eye-opening
i [ __ ] with that she's super super
funny i actually watched her [ __ ] she's
funny bro go watch it all right go
[ __ ] watch it watch it with your mom
too
jesus is coming you can watch your mom
and grandma and they're gonna [ __ ]
love her and it's a wild story
wild story oh one thing i forgot one
second real quick
guys i'm very sorry ida was telling me a
story about her and joey d as i said
please hold it for the podcast say that
on the on the podcast let's not talk
about it yet and then i forgot to bring
it up so anyway she got too high with
joey diaz one time and had to go to the
[ __ ] hospital off off the edibles off
the stars of death from joey diaz and i
forgot to have her talk about the story
so
next time she comes on we have to ask
not the first one either i will smash on
star's death with joey diaz and take
ball rips in his face like what's up
let's match just because i'm like yo
you're a weed smoking monster and so am
i
i love watching people start to
get [ __ ] get [ __ ] freaked out by
the edible throughout a podcast
yeah
that's why i don't do edibles on here
because i don't want people to get
[ __ ] up like
what they gotta tap out and [ __ ]
paulie shore went [ __ ] knots on his i
heard i heard they even air it
they cut it they cut it i was watching
it live when i was probably sure i got
too high
that's okay yeah yeah
but yes ida rodriguez kidnapped and on
the run please watch that episode
great [ __ ] episode
it was awesome
the very next guest which actually airs
today see where we film a week ahead
let's go today the be real episode drops
guys the be real episodes be real cyber
sales coming out
probably one of the
first rap groups i remember being
exposed to as a kid besides ice cube and
odb but also those are on their own i'm
almost listening to nwa she was an ice
cube she wasn't a wu-tang she doesn't
know db
you see what i'm saying so when it comes
to cypresses the first group i listen to
all the time as a kid and i've explained
it to him on the show so uh i met b-roll
a few times in different settings like
cannabis cup uh filming something else
he's cool he's chill
this b-roll i like this b-roll
this b-roll he's just hanging out he
doesn't have to do anything he's just
chilling that guy's cool
as [ __ ] last time i i met him one time
before and it was almost like a job
interview i went met with him to like
hire drastic graphics
and he wasn't all [ __ ]
having a good time and [ __ ] like he was
with us it was like more like a job
yeah when he was here i'm like yo this
guy's tight man this guy seems hella fun
and hella cool i like when fools are a
little bit goofy i like that [ __ ]
because it shows that you're not afraid
yeah somebody who you might think is
going to be serious yeah like oh gee
that's why i love og so much cause when
i first met him exactly
are you bumping the cranberries yeah
exactly
the scary garage
are you scary cousins the cranberries
yeah exactly
yeah
what's that doing
oh it's my chair i gotta stop moving
sorry i'm a squeaky ass [ __ ] okay i
almost thought it was a [ __ ] i
thought it's like a cricket no oh you
have the thing just for all you guys
that need it for you guys to remind you
of season one okay
there's the qriket again guys
here we go that's the end of my thing
all those guests back to back to back we
have shout out four guests in a row but
now it's just us let's talk [ __ ] let's
talk about dumb [ __ ] let's because when
i'm with other guests i can't be like
that
yes it's ridiculous
i was with hash house last night and
he's like bro i watched your we tube
video
he said you know what's really crazy
you're exactly the same on and off
camera no matter what i know [ __ ]
like there is no difference except
sometimes i say super offensive [ __ ]
because i want to see your face go
michael i know right that was [ __ ] up
wasn't it and then i just go back to my
life yeah this is funny to me i don't
mean to hurt anybody's feelings and i'll
get on to that topic
later but for now
i've gots to study okay hold on
watch big daddy last night let's go
what a good movie april made the best
suggestion of all time
do we need a nude girls neon behind me
on the set oh live nudes yeah yep like
that big big daddy
dude
um
so let's get into this guys
first topic that i want to talk about
sports
sports i one thing i've noticed is a lot
of these comedian nerd dudes are all
into ufc i don't mean nerds i mean like
you're not a buff athletic dude
but you're really they're all into
fighting every commit is because joe
rogan's their friend
uh kind of almost like that huh i think
it's because
that's a bad way no role
blurred the lines between podcasting and
then fighting and uh comedy okay because
i see almost every single [ __ ]
comedian or podcaster is into ufc heavy
because as a kid i was watching ufc one
to about 30. he actually ran him at
blockbuster so i was rare i can tell you
everything about everybody from 1995.
because i was watching so heavy i
stopped watching when i started doing
drugs
so i stopped being around tv like i'm
not gonna be home for the simpsons at
eight on sunday no more i am on cocaine
so
that's what happened
so i i'm lost looking at these new
fighters i'm like yo who is this guy oh
my god ah like i didn't know jorge
masada was even a fighter because i
remember him from kimbo slice [ __ ] yeah
he's the kid with the [ __ ] braids for
kimbo the long-haired kimbo slice and
from what i if that's the same dude okay
yeah
that's what i didn't know he was a real
fighter guys that is badass yes that's
like and one going into this league he's
like his hot sauce
was like yo i'm gonna just keep going
yeah
yeah wow that's funny yeah jorge
mossvadal is the rayford allston a
[ __ ] mma the what skip to my lou he
oh that's his name for all you know his
name
wow remember 50
with a broken tooth oh i thought yeah
yeah yeah wow [ __ ] yeah i've been on an
one bender ever since we've been [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] yo what's up professor come
over here sit down with us what's going
on
professor and then i want to go out
there and see if i could try to shake or
pick the professor
because i'm very good at you you would
do that you ever watch his instagram oh
yeah yeah dresses up like [ __ ] bugs i
want to see
if i cannot be crossed
i don't know about that i'm a big slow
dude so i'm not going to react to
everything you know what i mean like i'm
not going to be reacting and reaching in
so i want to see like yo
30 seconds to get by me and that's it
and if i don't can you take a picture
and i go like this uh-huh the time i
scold your ass but not really because
you beat the [ __ ] out of me
but still if i can make the fresh go
that's like me punching my ties i'm
going ow
like oh my god can you imagine the
stories he has from the tour bus being
the frail white boy
shake everyone on the bus
get out of ghetto could you imagine
escalade like that's my little homie
yeah picking him up by his head he was
like 13. he was a little boy yeah he's
not like 18 but he was a kid i used to
watch anyone so so heavily sorry
sports
here's the rant the rent is back here we
go sports you guys ready
cam newton is [ __ ] back all right and
i know a lot of people hate on sports
when i talk about sports because like
that guy suck nobody cares okay
nobody cares about your opinion bro
we're just stating our opinion and if
you care then that's cool but if not
it's still my opinion but when people
come in the comments like you're a piece
of [ __ ] you know about
nobody cares bro just keep it moving
um i just had to address that real quick
because when we talk about sports we get
a lot of it cam newton is a [ __ ]
physical specimen of a quarterback that
[ __ ] is a badass quarterback and
i stopped playing madden when he was on
the panthers anymore because that's the
only team i used he's unstoppable so
you're saying he had one bad season and
they [ __ ] no no no no no no no he
just
he fell off but dude pretty much this
way i watched football even doing drugs
but once i started selling drugs
sports were relevant to me i wasn't
there on sundays no more you know so i
started watching football heavily again
2018
for a day
like half a season that i fell off
so i just started watching football
again this year and i didn't even know
that half these players weren't even on
the teams anymore man when i saw certain
players like odell beckham's on the
browns
i thought he was a giant like that's how
long it's going to make you feel older
yeah
so
cam newton's back all right he's back on
the panthers last night they [ __ ] won
this fool spent the whole offseason
growing his dreads because though that
[ __ ] used to be a clean-cut ass
dude and that's the last time i saw him
so seeing all this [ __ ] is crazy i saw
colin kaepernick saying he might come
back
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on in sports
but my next thing uh guys
is a sadder part of sports because the
last time we talked about the raiders
was john gruden
resigning because he's an idiot
then this [ __ ] i know you saw
probably marty the [ __ ] wide receiver
for the raiders rugs riggs what's his
name rugs he [ __ ] killed that woman
in a [ __ ]
dumb ass mistake the nfl has uh car
services for their players
of course
and this was out here on 156.
god damn i didn't i didn't i don't know
the video details i just saw the picture
of it let's know i saw the video of
i mean
lightning
through an intersection
i have gone like 1 30ish on the freeway
by myself when there's nobody near me
because if i crash i'll kill myself only
and even then i went slow it down bro
there's no need for this and that's the
fastest i've ever gone i don't need to
go faster fashionable yeah i never want
to i never want to anything over 110 i'm
like all right bro
they're gonna say it's your fault it's
gonna be your fault if you die like
they're gonna make fun of you if you die
because i would like what the [ __ ]
wrong with you
anyway he killed some [ __ ] lady and
her dog all right
and he just got the contract
in vegas probably a brand new bomb ass
porsche that he was riding in probably
i'm assuming
and yeah man
kill this now he's going to prison no
more catching football man
you had a whole lifetime ahead of you of
being on espn
and you just had to get drunk which is
super [ __ ] sad because you know
there's nothing more in the world that
he wants that lady to live
not for jail purposes just like yo you
murdered this woman
i can't imagine the level of guilt that
comes with that i feel so bad about just
stupid [ __ ] bro i feel bad about cutting
somebody off by accident yeah exactly
real like legitimately yeah
yeah i don't know sad times [ __ ]
horrible i had a hobby accidentally
killed somebody a couple years ago in
the car
but they were the same [ __ ] age i
remember same as the kid was on vacation
damn and uh
yeah it was a horrible ordeal he just
got out of jail well how about on the
drive up here i'm driving up the [ __ ]
five god bro driving up the [ __ ] five
and i noticed there's a car facing the
wrong direction and then there's another
cars and they're stopped and then
there's somebody under the [ __ ] car
under the wheel
and it was like it just happened there
was a bunch of people pulled over but no
ambulance isn't [ __ ] yeah like that
puerto rican from [ __ ] ghost and when
he dies at the end he goes
and the demon people drag him away but
he slides under the tire
no when you said that it made me think
of howie mandel a little monster is
under the bed that's not what i'm
talking about i'm talking about ghost
not the blue monster that ally mandel
played with fred savage oh my god
he was under there though for real like
the tire was on him on the [ __ ] one
moment you're driving the next moment
the [ __ ] car is on outside of the car
under it that's when i go in the ocean
because i don't want to be getting eaten
by a shark going bro i was just smoking
bowls 40 minutes ago
that's what i don't want
yeah that's why i don't go in the ocean
i don't get on boats
no [ __ ] thank you if i'm drowning the
last thing i'm gonna think is i was just
on land yeah
it was all good 10 minutes ago yeah what
the [ __ ] dude
no
no dude i think about things like that a
lot cause i'm super paranoid about
things and final destination [ __ ] me
up as a kid yeah yesterday i was in
maholand drive and i saw this mansion
and the back door was a porch you know
exposed by the street and then it goes
straight down the mountain
the back door to this person's house was
the hill mm-hmm oh i mean if you're
drunk
yeah you could be in your own laundry
room and 40 seconds later falling to
your death into the street
and i thought about 10 million dollars
for death trap bro
no no like six feet away oh there's a
hill yeah no never want to go to
earthquake to [ __ ] yeah i think
that's why i moved my bed in my house in
my apartment
i realized hey the other side of this
wall is a [ __ ] 70-foot drop i'm
moving my bed and i moved at the other
side of the room cases are earthquake
and my wall opens um
being asleep to falling to your death
no thanks i've seen too many devin sawwa
movies
final destination is real okay
i always consider the worst case
scenario in everything it's just like
the automatic like
that's why i'm alive today if i was if i
wasn't this cautious i would have been
killed by the car in fresno
by that kid trying to shoot me in the
head
by three or four gangbangers i've talked
my way out of
yeah i mean i got stabbed a long time
ago or shot
so i'm cautious damn this is sports
sorry we're on sports
anyway the raiders super [ __ ] sad
that guy kid's life's over really really
sad
sorry i heard something my bad um sorry
what time are we at i feel like i'm just
dragged
how long until the [ __ ] cleveland
browns get canceled that [ __ ] what that
okay how are you orange first of all how
is your [ __ ] logo just orange
you're the browns that [ __ ] sounds
racist to me i don't think it's all the
races like [ __ ]
because they suck but i'm just saying in
our era of us canceling i mean you can't
think of a name but what about the
kansas city chiefs
that's what i'm saying why we got to
cancel them all right we're gonna go
full basketball
we're gonna go full basketball and the
san francisco was it san francisco was
the san jacinto ferries they called them
in basketball the texas felons
uh
the miami
uh
coke dealer or miami dealers and they
stood there with ice jackets
dea jackets and they ran away
yo basketball was mad offensive in the
best way i wish the earth was still
baseball funny
and i could say the [ __ ] i found in my
notes yesterday yeah i found some gold
in my notes that'll get me in trouble
i don't give a [ __ ] um
so
sports done guys let's hop into this
next thing i
this is just updating on what's been
going on since we last saw each other
all right what time are we at 46.
i'm not going to say it i'm going to say
what i'm trying to keep it under you
already know
you ready
so guys since november 3rd my homie
justin just came into town miami justin
boy he actually just left 10 [ __ ]
minutes ago before we started my homie
justin um i flew him in i periodically
he comes into town he's a really good
photographer
so i had him come in
took some pictures took some videos but
if you guys have been following for a
long time you will remember my little
brother and you remember bathroom hits
bathroom dabs if you remember that drop
a comment
every time on my social media i used to
drop smoking in the bathroom and you
know that means my little brother is at
my house
so no smoking i cleaned i used to clean
up all the bunks everything push them
into one closet take down all my
paintings take down every piece of
dopamile merch memorabilia throw it into
one closet where my brother stayed over
because
he would stay over for like four days my
little brother and he didn't know i
smoked he'd know nothing right
so from my 2014 you guys have seen me
bathroom dabs little brothers here
so my little brother's about to be an
adult i didn't put anything away my
little brother came on the sixth to like
the 12th
with my mom my mom and him stayed for a
bunch of days right
it was so odd being extremely high my
brother being there
it was so weird because that was like my
little kid
and now it's like
it's okay
this is so weird like i felt so odd my
paintings are up my bongs are out my
[ __ ] huge bong was in the corner i'm
like wait
i don't got to put it away smell like
you're some conspicuous dude though like
i mean i mean no no nobody's ever seen a
speck of anything ever i'm so meticulous
you come over my house you would never
know how he got high but i'm saying like
he knows you like he didn't find out
what i was doing until no no
i'm so good at playing this double life
[ __ ] bro i've been doing it since i
started smoking week as my mom my whole
family i told my grandma last year what
i do don't all his friends and [ __ ] know
like all about well no my brother knows
about like the past three years yeah but
i'm saying before that i didn't tell my
brother anything until like a year and a
half ago two years ago if that
because it's too hard to keep it from
and um
so guys
want to hear something crazy
every [ __ ] picture you see on push
trees isn't my little brother now he's
the model for my company now
because my little we have different dads
and when he was a baby girl you're going
to be so tall i could see you're like
6'3 bro my brother's like six [ __ ]
two
he's my brother and so weird looking up
like what my little brother holy [ __ ]
anyway he was made to take pictures
all right the second he's done with
school i'm going to try to
get him into everything my brother is
born to be a [ __ ] model he's got a
set of [ __ ] hair just look at him bro
he rock streetwear so [ __ ] perfectly
anyway all that [ __ ] brown-haired kid
all that [ __ ] is my little brother dude
it's very odd it's very odd seeing like
take all your pictures off we're making
you like a modeling account no you're
gonna be on a [ __ ] gucci ad next year
i can see it in his [ __ ] face he
looks like one of those super sharp
cheeked kids like he
if i was a manager of people i would
just be like oh i just found this kid
he's gotta be you know i mean like i
know i can see in people and he's got
that [ __ ] and he told me he wants to
start a clothing brand and he's got a
little mascot and a drawing it's so good
even if he's my brother i looked and
went bro this is tight i could see this
in zoomies today
one of those very poppy colors with a
character
it's [ __ ] cool
so anyway i brought that up because my
little brother is now almost grown and
all the push tree stuff you guys haven't
seen that's my little brother it's
[ __ ] weird to see it and my mom was
here it's just funny dude like
now that all the stories you guys hear
about my mom and
trying to kill me over the weed or kill
me over being doing nothing
now
i'm just taking dabs and my mom's like
you're coughing so much i know
she's standing right there it's so weird
to me she's donating to the chat she was
donating you see the video
which one oh wait oh i have a video
coming out on the we tube and uh there's
a video i'm doing the chat and my mom's
behind me and i could see her [ __ ]
donate oh you did see it okay i was on
that lab okay
so yes oh it was online that's right but
it's in a video
anyway it's very odd my little brother's
been doing so much [ __ ] for my clothing
it's cool to see
and then
what up what else is that oh yeah sorry
i'm just trying to update you guys on
what's been going on for the past
since we saw you i haven't been able to
check in in a [ __ ] month no and i've
been every day doing so every [ __ ]
day
oh if you guys want to check out some
stuff there's an app or a website called
the weed tube
all right the weed tube is made by a
bunch of youtubers that made weed
content that got deleted years ago like
i used to get deleted all the time they
just made their own app because they
were tired of it and i've been posting
on that app go check it out i did how to
sell weed video because youtube would
never let me do that right so i did on
wetube how to sell eat uh
never before heard story times around
there vlogs and [ __ ] go check out the we
tube my name is dopaziola official just
literally i just want to tell you guys
that because i've been filming so
[ __ ] much stuff because it's
uncensored i can do mushrooms on there i
can show a bunch of [ __ ]
so i've been filming so many videos on
that channel
youtube channel i haven't had a day
i've had a day to sit and go
my house is dirty i haven't been grocery
shopping one of those times of life you
know what i'm saying where it's just
non-stop i have no time for [ __ ]
anything
except today
today after this you know it's 11 in the
morning right now
yes in time
i can go get some more and it's done i
just i'm
i'm excited but uh
yeah so what we've been doing this since
we've seen you guys last it's been busy
marty
what's up with your house
we're coming in the final stages of this
[ __ ] what's happening also
marty's the only person to plant it with
a finished garage oh man that was my
[ __ ] moment finished garage guys that
was the big one that was the big one yep
whoa we got the epoxy floor going with
the [ __ ] fresh walls
i'm gonna do you one better i'm gonna do
one better we got the insulated garage
door coming in all alright it's that
garage door oh yeah
because i don't think i've ever heard of
that yeah yeah because i'm going to use
it like an office so that keeps the ac
in it keeps it smart dude yeah cause
uh
yeah my neighbor is a [ __ ] police
officer so this fool's out there [ __ ]
putting around in the morning i mean i
was at your house at 8 30 in the morning
yeah you know help me move this dryer
tom i'm saying all right and your
neighbors out there underneath this rv
doing a bunch of [ __ ] already hilarious
i love that the universe is [ __ ]
funny
yeah but he's cool though yeah as long
as he's cool better yeah he's legal [ __ ]
yeah yeah do a thing except hey i'm
piece of [ __ ] i live next door to you
he's one of those like la cops that
doesn't give a [ __ ] about weed like he's
like cool that's cool like you know
that's the one thing i never got about
people people call people pieces of [ __ ]
or like lola you know neighbor feuds
you live next door
what does that say about your financial
state yeah i've considered that
yeah when people call me fat when
they're fat go what
it's the same thing like
yeah but the house we just ordered all
the counters and [ __ ] guys you've been
here every step of the way it's getting
really cool isn't that crazy you've been
building your house on this on the
[ __ ] podcast for five months yeah and
i just posted on my story like our
little checklist of everything that we
have left and what it's going to cost
it's like you know
i added it up i'm like damn that's a lot
but it doesn't seem like a lot compared
to everything we've done
and once that [ __ ] is done
i saw your house yeah it's awesome i'm
excited to see it done yeah the
backyard's way tighter than it looks
like in pictures
way way cooler yeah way cool private do
it all up it's gonna be [ __ ] great it
feels amazing it feels weird it really
feels weird of course you grossed us
without money yeah it's just it feels
supposed to feel yeah it's supposed to
feel like this
can i sit everywhere yeah i don't i know
it's not like yeah yeah it allows you to
whole situation and i just i i had to
part ways one of my main most long-term
clients of all time
uh well dude since you started
yeah this
literally just this past weekend you did
yeah i've i've
i've parted ways with like five of my
main clients because the podcast has
become so successful and i'm needing to
give it my attention but that like guys
it's like it affects just it's [ __ ]
weird because i work so hard to get so
many clients and now you're like i'm
letting them go it's [ __ ] weird
it really feels weird it is weird but
like the coolest we yeah and in the best
way possible in the best way and they
should all be happy and they are
and they are
that's so cool yeah that's so sick it's
like it was weird letting go of like you
know like i've been with these fools
five six seven eight nine years some of
these dudes and it's like i've relied on
them most the time i it hasn't been the
position where i've been up on the
[ __ ] upswing the whole time but like
now it's like they're like nah bro you
got to go for it [ __ ] go for it yeah
yeah
it's cool man it's cool it's cool i
really like it yeah i think
you need a honeydew episode
i could do it [ __ ] i tried to do a
honeydew episode shout out to ryan
sickler i'm scared to go on honeyduke
only because there's [ __ ] like there's a
lot of stuff in my life that if you were
to peel back one little piece of it
like there's [ __ ] i can't there's [ __ ]
that if i were to go into people would
people would be [ __ ] hurt
what do you mean people oh people that
get involved in it
that's why i don't talk about nightmares
and the [ __ ] because because some people
are still like i always say some people
are still alive bro i can't really yeah
that [ __ ] like i would love to do a
honeydew i would love to do it on here
there's certain [ __ ] that
we'll get into but like
i told ryan when i first met him bro
like i'm i'm more i might need a dr drew
episode if you want to get into some
honeydew [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] goes deep but
yeah i would love that i'm excited for
your next episode of come on
yes i just did a honeydew episode it was
basically
an hour and a half story time
we didn't do anything at all except why
don't you tell me about this tell me
about this it was back to back to back
just story after story after story after
story after story and at the end it went
that's my life
that's a [ __ ] fraction of it that's
exactly how i felt after my episode on
here yeah it's like it's only a little
the thing is
i'm not one of those people that's ever
been like holding something inside it
makes me you know something like that's
gonna [ __ ] your kid up later that's
gonna like when steve was talking about
abandonment yeah
not for me mm-hmm i'm the same person
whether my mom did or did not beat the
[ __ ] out of me yeah like nothing of that
[ __ ] none of the oh he grew up without a
dad yeah he's gonna need like no my dad
was never there and i don't give a [ __ ]
my mom showed me to throw a football and
i am the best [ __ ] quarterback i know
i'm very good at it as you can tell from
the 75 gram cross joint video when i was
[ __ ] faced drunk and i beat the [ __ ]
game twice in one round
i don't know who else has been doing
that [ __ ] cam newton uh-huh but if you
ever want to wear [ __ ] fedoras
together and throw some [ __ ]
footballs let me know
yeah dude how do you do it honeydew
episode drops
thanksgiving weekend thanksgiving week
nice yeah he told me and uh that was
great man i need you ryan sickler
but yeah i think you should that would
be a cool episode for you to be on there
i love
because you know so many people
i love so much that you're talking to
the microphone more
like and you're actually doing it it's
the first ones it was like yeah producer
marty marty chimes in
it's not that way anymore i love it so
much
better this way yeah i don't know i
didn't really notice that but i guess if
you're able to go back and listen yeah
so yeah yeah big time the first episode
you you're chiming in
not
the conversation yeah and now it's like
we're in the conversation it's just way
better i just like that people are like
it's like i don't know how to explain it
but i read all the comments and i answer
the comments so i read what you guys say
so i you know what's crazy is i can
remember most people's comments because
of the picture i screenshot it in my
head of their profile picture
that's how i associate everybody's with
everyone's everything everything
yeah we got the message fans on earth i
appreciate it i think about people's
comments constantly it really always
because you got a rubber dude
you do it easy because you just do music
it's so hard to be on camera
for somebody that's not done it yeah oh
i i know oh sure my god it you might as
well
it's like running naked through the mall
it's like it's just as scary
i can honestly say there's never been
one time i've probably been in a
thousand studio sessions in front of all
kinds of people i've there's never been
one time i didn't get up on the market
and [ __ ] go
yeah that and i've always knew that was
unique
oh my gosh i loved that because it was
like
a lot of people would be [ __ ] freaked
out by this [ __ ]
go you know what i mean like how crazy
is that how crazy is that like uh it's i
know leave it in the comments because i
know some of you guys think i love being
able to go hey
left side of california hey i mean of
america hey other side of america what's
up
and then earth right here in the middle
so i go hey tell me if you guys think
about this have you ever been like uh
so nervous to do something because it's
embarrassing like talk in front of class
right you've been ready to talk in front
of class
and you couldn't think of one thing to
talk about even though you have your
notes and you're like i don't remember
oh my god this is gonna be bad but then
there's times like yo anybody come up
and talk about your favorite movie
and then you go up there and crush it
it's so odd to me thinking of
thomas i would never want to go up in
front of a crowd and do something you
know that's how you think yeah and now
it's like
who cares i don't care if it's 50 it'd
be weirder if there was five people
watching me on a stage than a hundred
thousand for sure
that's how i change the whole crowd
yeah like i don't give a [ __ ] now i
don't have like i don't have the stage
fright [ __ ] i don't have any of that
which is i'm so lucky because i used to
be so bad when i first when he first
asked me to host some of the cannabis
cup [ __ ]
you want me on the stage
can i just like be on the side throwing
stuff i just felt odd yeah it's like why
am i gonna be on stage and i got up
there and everybody's yelling and hell
hyped oh it's different when they're
your fans too i didn't know how it was
gonna be you know what you're saying
[Music]
so that like having the fans like be
stoked i think took away a lot of that
too because it's so much easier to go up
and it's like yo you guys are [ __ ]
ready versus what's up my name is thomas
oh my god man i got so [ __ ] crunk
when i saw philippe's fans and when i i
just went and filmed sickler at the bray
improv like that's man i think you get
that first live show under your belt you
come out
dude comedians all the podcasts rock
stars are like this to me yeah they're
just as important
and their their
popularity
is just as important like it's just as
impactful
maybe not over the course of time
because jokes cannot be funny like 30
years later but music will still be
[ __ ] awesome i get that
but seeing
like ryan ryan's cool guy josh great guy
super sick night you gotta remember oh
yeah you guys got a worldwide [ __ ]
following of people just love your
[ __ ] comedy so much but i just see
you as a funny ass dude yeah no and then
i forget like oh you're a professional
funny ass dude every person after
particular shows like
i drove here from six hours away you
changed your podcast changed my life i
love you so much thank you so much like
one after the other after the other it's
great bro what better job can you have
than to go make people laugh and affect
them that way when you're not making
them laugh like that's what i love about
the whole model of it dude i have such a
good you know i have great memories so i
remember a lot of fans
and i remember people from like nine
years ago
and there was one all right real quick
real quick story
he's probably watching this right now
there was a fan
that was dming me before dm's it was
commenting to me
like i'm a huge fan oh well i'm buy some
merch i don't know what it was about it
was very [ __ ] cool
so i wrote a note in his package i'm
like yo i'm gonna give you this
one-of-one
uh
buck hat i made it was like a wax one
but i never put it out because i didn't
like the underneath and i wanted to
switch it up
but i ended up never making it
sorry
anyway i sent it to him
he lost his [ __ ] commented back so
excited thank you if i ever [ __ ] meet
you i'm gonna give you a gram dab the
second i see you i'm not gonna even
shake your [ __ ] hand like i love your
hat i'm like all right bro cool secret
four years later i'm at an event just
standing there and some guy walks up to
me with a [ __ ] rig and a fat ass
piece of hash like what's up man i go
sup dude
are you gonna take it down he's like yo
what's up i'm so-and-so and so and he
had the hat on look to the hat and go
damn he had it on get the hat on i went
oh [ __ ] i gotta take a gram dab right
now [ __ ]
no hey what's up bro just oh bro [ __ ]
and i took the [ __ ] whole thing right
there and then we started talking but i
remember thinking
you held your word [ __ ] knew i
was at an event you had it heated you
walked up
go like
four years later
holy [ __ ] so like seeing the fans and
how hyped they are but you know like i
defense
shout out to all you guys seeing
everywhere i see you guys i [ __ ] love
you guys but seeing like the impact that
the comedian can have is so cool
i mean
that's what we get every day and i love
that so i want to do it in person
doing doing [ __ ] in person like to me
all right stand up [ __ ] i get it like
you're saying uh
we're gonna do live shows i get it i
know i'm gonna have to
you know let's not even talk about it
yet let's just build and work on it last
time we mentioned this you're saying
you're gonna throw dildos on the crowd
i did yeah
why
i don't know because you're gonna be so
excited
i said these words yeah
you sure uh-huh
i was just listening back from the
episodes yeah okay then i was saying
[Laughter]
but why a dildo
because it's funny yeah yeah okay
that's like that'd be funny seeing those
flying to hit people that's funny as
[ __ ]
what if one stuck a bald guy
and it's stuck
yo stop what time we at
it's how we at here
oh 46. i'm so sorry i'm so sorry 45
minutes of me just
being in dumbass dancing around these
topics
for real huh i'm sorry guys rant city
sorry let's get back into it
here we go so yesterday i went to the
laker game and my friends got the boxy
the really baller huge boxy uh
booths like with a bar and a [ __ ]
buffet in it
i don't ever want to go to a [ __ ]
basketball or sports game ever again not
like that
i'll probably get kicked out if i say
this
i want to go back to laker games
you know what let's just leave it at
that i went to a laker game yesterday
and i was in there
what the [ __ ] did you do there i
i'm not gonna say it
i may have done something i'm not
supposed to do anyway it was really fun
i'm so afraid of heights i had to sit by
the like in the back
so there was kind of a pointless i had
to like look to see because i couldn't
sit at the edge of our booth because i'm
[ __ ] afraid of heights it made me
feel dizzy and uh
went to the game super [ __ ] fun i
don't ever want to go to any games
without a boxy it was the most fun it
was a nightclub by yourself with your
friends yeah restaurant what
holy [ __ ] anyway that was super fun went
there yesterday very cool
then let's go to my other topic i got
right here my other topic i got right
here all right
last weekend i went to the office event
you guys know my favorite show of all
time is the office you guys know that
rosie got these tickets like a month ago
and we happened to buy the very last
ticket
so we either winners of a dundee we got
a special dundee a dundee is a trophy
from the show they do a award show in
the show
and that's the trophy they get anyway
we went i'm not saying anything bad but
i will say
the office event
was me just watching the office
outside
with food trucks
uh that's all i'm gonna say okay
i guess it was cool i guess it was cool
that's a [ __ ] but
i mean i guess it was cool the
background was the downtown la skyline
we were at the park right before
downtown so the background was badass
but
i left the last episode
because i'm like you know what i'm done
my back is i'm sitting on grass this
hurts
let's leave and then oscar from the
office shows up
to like hey what's up guys like [ __ ] man
that's why i wanted to go see if i can
see any of these in the office anyway
went to the office event
and that's it that's all i was gonna say
i'm gonna summon it up like i'm trying
to give you guys a summary of what i've
been doing
because
i've been doing so much
so much we went to the lewis ck show we
saw louis ck live my homie got it for my
birthday uh but yeah i was just two
months ago but the tickets preferred now
went and saw louis ck live went to my
friend's house to smoke weed and then
we're gonna drive to the show as you're
smoking weed he goes hey i'm gonna put
on the stand up i think you're gonna
like it this guy named shane gillis
never heard of him in my [ __ ] life
and says unless he was the guy from the
snl thing where they were like yo he
said something about asian people i'm
like okay
but he got canceled right i don't know
what he said so maybe i shouldn't win
okay maybe he said something really bad
i don't know
[ __ ] just look into that
anyway the man's hilarious
we're watching his set and i'm like yo
this guy is hysterical we're watching
his youtube set you should go watch it's
on youtube shane gillis
we go to the [ __ ] louis ck show and
the opener who shane gillis had no idea
he finished the set that i was watching
at tyler's house
like we had to leave like all right
let's go show we watched like 30 minutes
of it
and then he did the rest of it
it was really cool to see it
and then go live and see it a lot it was
like inception and
it was so odd anyway that man is [ __ ]
hysterical
i found out he has a thing called gilly
and reeves or something it's a skit show
and it's like skits i used to try to do
he said he does some really good and not
on iphones
like i used to do in 2015.
your gavel one that was fun though
one time i judged a hash festival so i
went and bought an entire judge's white
curly-haired like 1800s judge outfit
with a gavel and i was taking dabs and
every time like this one's trash then
i'd hit the caval and grade it it was
pointless i don't even think i put the
video up yeah i don't even think i did i
got to be honest anyway shane gillis was
hysterical went and watched louis ck
um i think we talked about it josh wolf
did his high life i don't know if we
talked about it on here
josh eat a lot of mushrooms and then ate
kept eating them and i was gonna go drop
them off at a sun jake's baseball game
son jake went to go play softball or
some [ __ ] right so he left and i'm like
yo i'll take you don't get no uber on
mushrooms
josh was really [ __ ] up on mushrooms
to the point where he was starting
sentences and just not doing anything
else how much did he eat he probably ate
like two or three grams it's a lot but
while on live we were on live and as
we're going down the freeway i'm like
josh you're good
yeah buddy
yeah man
hella late his reactions were heavily
and then there was a time on the freeway
where he was talking to me and he just
stopped and i went like this
looked in the rear view at rosie like yo
he's [ __ ] gone
oh
my god melting back there yes we get to
the softball uh field he calls jake's
like where yeah he's like oh my god
you're already there i'm 15 minutes away
it's dark it's a softball field
and the round is like some wooded area
it looks kind of scary
there's a lot of trees
and i looked at josh i'm like
i'm gonna wait with you bro he goes
thank you
like he didn't want to ask he's like
thanks man it's like i didn't want to
wait by myself out here oh dude it's
scary out here i'm not going to leave
you [ __ ] up he goes thanks man and
then we're sitting there we're hanging
out
like 15 minutes and he goes
oh okay i'm back
i wasn't on the planet for a while ago
josh you were starting and just not
finishing sentences
man oh
man damn man well yeah all right
so then he left
and then tuesday
uh i'm getting into this chronologically
because this is one week of what
happened the next day we finalized
everything for our new company i have a
new company coming out drops december
1st i am overly hyped
remember i told you i got too [ __ ] up
off this edible and i almost drove my
uber
this is our brand it's called the dopest
all right
it's called the dopest why
because we have pens edibles hash rosin
[ __ ]
chocolates
so when on the packaging it's going to
be like oh these are the gummy sharks
the dopest gummy sharks the dopest
grape pie pin the dopest og kush pen
that way it can never end and it's
always the dopest whatever the [ __ ] we
make you know it's like it's like a play
on it just always the dopest this the
dopest stat
it's pretty awesome yeah so on instagram
we made it the dopest shop that's what
it's on instagram it's the dopest shop
we posted it we have no pictures and
there's almost eleven thousand [ __ ]
followers on one damn day crazy you guys
are badass and that shows me that you
guys are excited so i'm excited and
marty knows because i told martin like
two other people
we dropped december 1st we weren't going
to do any wholesale whatsoever
we were going to do retail just to start
off see how much our first order we know
how much we have to do to make a certain
amount of money so we're like let's see
if we can sell this how fast can we sell
that
then
somebody hit us up for the biggest
[ __ ] colso order
that it's
somebody asked us hey
you're not doing wholesale what if i put
in this order and we all collectively
went
it threw up from excitement that's how
excited we were i [ __ ] puked i was
pacing around the [ __ ] warehouse just
like oh my god
you're [ __ ] kidding me and yeah it's
real we put our first order our first
sale
is so astronomically [ __ ] high
that
it's a really great way to start this
off yeah
i am like
hmm maybe i will get that house a couple
months earlier than i thought
maybe i can up that price on zillow when
i'm searching now holy [ __ ]
anyway it's more money than i've ever
made legally or illegally ever in one
time ever in life
ever
times
[ __ ] two or three
so i'm very excited about that and
that's just the first order so i'm
[ __ ] hyped guys it's gonna be
anywhere you can buy this at 7 11.
that scare the [ __ ] out of me
that scared me so [ __ ] violent right
here in my chest
so i'm excited guys it's coming out
december 1st the dopest the dopest shop
on instagram
very very very very [ __ ] hyped let's
go it's weird it's weird
that that was a weird yeah that that was
a very casual little introduction to
this [ __ ] it's going to be [ __ ] huge
it already is [ __ ] huge it's already
the biggest thing ever but
wow
so basically guys it's legal hemp
derived products except
our cannabinoid will [ __ ] you up and i'm
saying this not to sell it to you
because i ate a thousand milligrams and
almost threw up my uber while having to
take a [ __ ] remember i told you
so i almost threw up this is the best ad
well my stomach hurt already and i was
eating all those candies i was hungry
and i was hitting the pens and went oh
so [ __ ] up oh my god but i have to go
to the bathroom i'm in the uber
and then i'm like
i'm a [ __ ] throw up i [ __ ] almost
i got too high i was sitting there
oh my god i got i got the spins oh my
god no and i put my head against the
guy's glass because it's kind of cold
you know what i'm saying when you're
[ __ ] up and i'm sitting there going
and i held rosie's handwriting
i'm sitting there and i'm like 10
minutes from my house and i'm like
and i might [ __ ] my pants
so i'm sitting there like don't throw up
don't shake your pants don't throw my
hand don't know i'm just like
the dopest animals ever
i'm gonna die dope is diarrhea
god dude
yeah no there was no way it was the
candy because it was i already you know
my stomach already hurt i had to go the
bathroom
but
being that [ __ ] up just made me think
i'm just driving my own car this is
[ __ ] why don't you take an uber
today [ __ ] this
good thing i did i was so violently
[ __ ] up i went home oh i post on
twitter i slept for [ __ ] 14 [ __ ]
hours
and i'm an insomniac i slept for like
seven at night and i woke up the next
day almost in the afternoon thinking
that was [ __ ] awesome
what
bear hibernation it's damn i'm so off
topic sorry
anyway the company's coming out guys i'm
so [ __ ] excited it's very very cool
that's out as [ __ ]
it's super sick marty's house is almost
done the office event what time we at
let's see here
57 really
i got a i got a quick funny little
office story i don't know if i ever
really fully told you
go okay holy we're doing really good
yeah yeah i know it feels like i'm yeah
we're getting along here okay
go for it i think i know what [ __ ]
story you're talking about i never
watched the office so i don't know
anything about it
all right which makes it better
so
we got a package at our door
we got a package at our door and there
was like it was like in
brown paper there was like arabic
writing on it like we couldn't even tell
where it was from because it was from a
foreign country
it was addressed to our house to april
so we looked at it like what the [ __ ] is
this
it's weird like shoebox maybe even
bigger than that bigger than a shoebox
so
we're kind of like inspecting it
i like i'm already sketched out by it
i've never seen like postage marks like
this and [ __ ] before but it's addressed
to april
so i like open it up with a knife
and i like look inside of it and it's
white styrofoam
and on the top of it there's a hole cut
out
and there's like some black plastic and
it's like ticking and it's taped
with like a bomb masking tape
so
immediately i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this
like i'm i got kind of scared for a
second
like i like put it down
it's literally ticking
it's taped
in this it's in it's like a styrofoam
[ __ ] damn dirty bomb yeah so
uh we had the neighbors kids over now
our neighbors in this house were
like
we're
like strict muslims
okay so our neighbors but they're
they're like best friends with our kids
but they i mean it just that's who they
are
it's just funny that you're like
this this is your packaging no
i'm setting the i'm setting the scene
here so we got there like three kids
over at our house
and
now we're really great friends with the
mom but we've really never met the dad
all like that i don't even really know
the dad
okay so i get this package
we got their kids over they're just
running around
and then i show april and april's like
you we need to call the cops this is
this couldn't be any sketchier yeah the
[ __ ] is this
so the white family has terrorist bombs
no no i should i should have mentioned
that they were muslim and [ __ ] but just
to set the scene before i think
the white family's got the muslim i mean
the arabic writing
so now okay so we i think we call the
cops
and they send a sheriff over
all right the sheriff gets there now our
neighbor next door the dad i'd only met
this dude maybe once or twice in like
the two years we live there
he comes over to pick up the kids
in the moments that he's in the house a
[ __ ] sheriff walks in
okay
the dude the sheriff walked in the house
okay he's he's in his full like they
wear the traditional clothes and [ __ ]
he's in his full [ __ ] homeboy leaves out
of the house without even taking his
he kids out of the house i noticed this
[ __ ] afterwards i'm like tell me that he
left in the kitchen
that's not the sketchy [ __ ] okay that's
just a side sketch in the [ __ ] story
all right i thought that [ __ ] was
hilarious when i realized that so he
dipped out the kids are still there so
now the kids are all in the backyard i
put the thing out in the [ __ ]
backyard the sheriff comes over and he's
like all right everybody in the house
so we all all the kids go on the house
and then he starts inspecting this
package i see him get on his [ __ ]
phone or whatever the guy with the high
school education is looking at the bomb
yeah gotcha exactly
and then he's like he's like this is
really [ __ ] weird i'm i need to take
this in that's is his observation
this is really [ __ ] weird
he just he's like handling it and [ __ ]
you know
like he's just a dude he looked like me
you're just a dude that's so sad like
he's a regular person going
yeah sounds [ __ ] up
his assessment was like mine this is
[ __ ] strange
so then he brought it in they brought it
into the [ __ ]
police station
and they inspect it
and they send me they call me like
probably the next day
and they send me this [ __ ] horrifying
picture that i'll splash up on the
screen right now yes
and the picture was so like
terrifying to me
that my immediate thought was like oh
there's a [ __ ] serial killer toying
with us like
it never my first thought was like oh
god they do do they are they're finding
fingerprints on this also don't flash
the picture yet in the edit okay okay
party remember don't do that okay here's
editing my guy not marty editor marty
don't flash the picture until you start
until you twist okay okay okay all right
so yeah so they sent me the picture and
i think a million thoughts in three
seconds all right the the the creep from
[ __ ] saw is toying with us all right
this is some
because it's just this [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] picture
and then the cop goes do you know who
this is
and i'm like no
he's like it's i think it does it don't
say yeah oh man i mean because
because the way he said it
marty when you told me the story you
showed me the picture i went
this
is the water you served to your place
that's why i feel like what this is who
you were scared of what's his name
proceed go ahead
i don't even know the dude's name
kevin malone from the office like this
he just got like a weird face going
marty thought it was a serial killer but
it was a clown it was a clock it's like
oh okay [ __ ]
okay
that's so weird
so we're still like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on oh god i'm
like is there a bomb in it where's the
bomb no it's just a fun clue no it's a
clock
so then we call april's mom and we tell
april's mom what happened and she's like
mortified we still don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on
come to find out
april's sister who is overseas ordered
off ebay this [ __ ] clock for her
other sister in california and shipped
it to our house and didn't tell us
so that's then her sister has the
audacity to go could you go pick up the
clock it's a gift for ashley that's a
sick clock i want that clock no i should
have went and got him like i'm not going
to kevin maloney police station how
[ __ ] funny guys
that marty basically called the bomb
squad
because there's a
kevin malone clock that scared him
that's funny imagine how horrifying
though how you would package a clock
yeah i get it in styrofoam it's got the
black [ __ ] it i can't get the
i love it so much
so
that's the office connection that we did
i went to the office and marty called
the bomb squad
that's funny
hey what's up guys welcome to the mid
roll ad read want to give a special
shout out to one of our sponsors this is
on it before we start remember go to
www.onit.comit.com forward slash yola
and that's 10 off of anything on the
website except for the weights again
that's
www.onit.com forward slash yola it's 10
off so let's get right into this guys on
it just released so much new [ __ ] there
is now a plant-based protein powder and
you know me i am a fat person but i'm
also [ __ ] vegan too and i'm very
strict with that [ __ ] so having
plant-based protein powder is awesome
because i've been using so many
different brands because i don't know
what i like not any of them
i can see the difference i am very
excited to try honest version of the
plant-based protein powder human
optimization is their [ __ ] so i'm
excited to see if it works for me so ana
is introducing something called instant
packets remember the new mood the pills
you could take or the alpha brain now
it's in packets you know when you just
cut it open put in your water just like
that as i said before go to onit.com
check out everything that's o-n-n-i-t
dot com forward slash jola is 10 off it
can't hurt guys if you have any desire
at all if this interests you even a
little bit just try it out plus using
our code helps us out alright it helps
us out helps the podcast it helps
everything grow we appreciate it
speaking of bombs are you ready
bomb will make sense i don't know why
but lately since my homie justin was
here my job was justin's just as bad
with the references
he has all the same references i do it
gets ridiculous
i've been trying to go hard
all right
so i've been doing this thing lately
let me just show you marty did i ever
tell you about the time
i was late to my kid's uh recital no
they said my kids my kids recital i'm
like yo my kids having a recital [ __ ]
the freeway's packed so i went on the
shoulder and i'm just smashing smashing
smashing i'm almost to the end i get
pulled over
i get pulled over yes
it's near christmas time i get their
recitals over he's pissed we go back
home and i'm like yo what can i do to
make it better man ah [ __ ] nothing [ __ ]
so i found out he really wants this toy
but the toy is hella hard to get i go to
a bunch of stores i go to a bunch of
places it's sold out everywhere people
are fighting over this damn toy right
then i find out there's this place
that sells the toy like black market i
go there there's a bunch of gang bangers
basically dressed the same
all dressed the same and we get this big
old rumble and i don't get any of the
[ __ ] toys i leave i find out
this radio station's giving away this
[ __ ] toy i go there and then me and
[ __ ] sinbad start fighting over this
damn toy and then
anyway i got that far into explaining
the plot of jingle all the way
with turbo man and arnold schwarzenegger
and justin's sitting there knowing i
don't have a [ __ ] child
and he was following him rosie was two
for a while i'm gonna go from
anyway i have just been saying i'm the
main character of movies until someone
goes hey
i know that movie okay finally
[ __ ] i love that so anyway i was
a lion right and my dad was the king of
the [ __ ] jungle hey and then my uncle
just killed his ass in this wildebeest
see
that makes me
happy forever
knowing that i can walk up to a stranger
and tell them a [ __ ]
full movie like i do you know so many
obscure movies and i could say it just
like that
the bangers that all dressed the same
was remember when he goes on sorcery
tries to buy the turbo man and all those
santa clauses are dressed the same they
all fight i said it like that so you
wouldn't go santa clauses
man you thought so i didn't lie that was
a game they were all just the same yeah
anyway
love jingle all the way it's turbo time
i've been doing that a lot lately to
people
bro it's my new favorite thing i love
your flavor of [ __ ] with justin oh i
[ __ ] with my friend justin boyd so hard
anyway that's what i've been doing to
people lately all right and it's making
me just
so happy
i forgot i used to do things like this
to people and it makes me laugh imagine
me
not paying attention in class
oh god bro it got it gets so severely
bad
the [ __ ] i used to do to people just to
like hear myself like thomas shut up why
are you lying it's a movie like
that's a movie i know i'm waiting for
them to get it they don't get it
anyway um
that's my new thing
that's what i've been doing and last
night real quick if
if you think like i do
then you'll find this funny and i know
we're just getting into random [ __ ]
right now but today's a fun time for me
that's what we're here for
there's this like a stage curtain like a
really nice theater curt in the box
seats of the laker game and it's real
dark in there like in there just the bar
lights are on so you can see the game
and there's this curtain i'm like yo
that curtain is perfect
i'm doing it right now see there's no
reason for me to do these things
but i walked over to it and hidden
behind it and i text justin that was
sitting right there
and i text him and now i'm reaping all
the benefits and he's like and he saw
him look at the text go what he looks at
me and i move the curtain over my face
and then he goes what and i got so upset
at him for not understanding that i was
doing john lovitz as the wedding singer
when [ __ ] adam sandler decides not to
be a wedding singer anymore and he sings
the song and he's i'm and then the
curtain jesus christ that's a deep
[ __ ] i know but if you know what i'm
talking about you're gonna go
bro
that was uh what
because if i saw someone do that go can
we be [ __ ] friends that's like og
miming the [ __ ]
the door
yes yeah
yes from american me it's the same thing
except i did it normally no just gave no
[ __ ] background or context you just
did this anyway
i was so upset when he didn't get it
but that's what i've been doing lately
all right justin my friend has been here
for a week and a half we've been filming
non-stop
i filmed two hash rosin videos and i
smoked almost a half a zip of hash since
he's been here god damn and i am so high
i'm just tired
i've gone through almost 4 8 jars since
he's been here which is not a shitload
but it is a shitload of hash rosin and
i've been so sleepy and tired and just
editing
videos that we filmed that day
and i've just been doing that just
trying to bust out as much content while
he's here taking pictures all that [ __ ]
that i have just been eating like [ __ ]
eating in the middle of the night
i'm 20 years old right now is what's
going on i'm back in college i feel like
that too and i'm just everywhere right
now and then making [ __ ] references
because i don't have any
responsibilities and we don't have a
goddamn sink and dishwasher and [ __ ]
fridge
that doesn't help either i've been
eating like a real piece of [ __ ] lately
guys when you're building a kitchen you
need counters in order to have sinks and
dishwashers fyi not that
i'm talking about people having no
responsibilities
and i don't have a sink
he's thinking about me damn it thomas
you're over there making stupid
references because you have nothing to
do
i don't have a sink
and washing dishes in the [ __ ] shower
and [ __ ]
yeah like creamer you're making dinner
in the shower
sorry guys sorry what time were you at
let's say 19 11 11.
all right sorry
sorry for that anyway marty got scared
by kevin malone i went to the office
event we just watched office outside
i guess
yeah and then um
let's get back on topic
after we're all goofy and funny and fun
here's my next topic
don't [ __ ] care
i truly don't give a [ __ ]
and here's the topic are you right you
ready
i'm just gonna talk about it real quick
because i want people to know how i feel
the past
month and a half i've been getting oddly
a lot of
confrontation
i don't know why but i've been getting a
lot of
a lot of people trying me lately online
but like
i know you're like stop looking at it
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about
controversial topics maybe
like when i talked about dave chappelle
thing
or something else or something else i
don't know something i did
um there's a lot of people that think i
care
there's a lot of people and i got
deleted again and i think that's why
probably is why it's probably
i posted on my account i was about to
it's [ __ ] 200k again or 300k again ah
oh no 100k again that was the last two
months i got the other account right i
was going to hit 100k again
it was like 200k i don't [ __ ] care or
no all right i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
instagram
i remember i was thinking oh hit another
cool and i got deleted because i think a
two days before i posted what i'm about
to talk about
i think things are funny you don't have
to
if i'm eating something you're like i
don't like that stuff well you have to
eat it too no i don't i want to go over
here you can do that with the [ __ ] you
watch
if you don't agree or like it don't
[ __ ] look at it
people's parents are coming at us
talking about better business bureau
because their kids bought push trees
gear
with the credit card that their parents
opened for them
and it says 21 or over on our [ __ ] so
your kid
said yes when he's not i've had a lot of
moms
call us pieces of [ __ ] lately and i told
rosie
let me get the next one
because i am going to make this bomb
erase her
throw her whole phone away
because first off [ __ ] do a better job
as a parent and know what your kid's
buying with the credit card that you
opened it's a sweater [ __ ]
it doesn't even have weed on it first
off but if you don't like that it's fine
but don't come at me because you're a
bad parent you know how much weed your
kid is buying if they're buying weed
clothes clothes
thank you
how many times he called you a stupid
[ __ ] probably a lot if you open a
credit card for him and he's buying weed
[ __ ] when you tell him don't
if i did something my mom said not to
i'm the bad one
right i can try to imagine me
complaining to a company for some [ __ ]
like this dude i've gotten a lot of
complaints my favorite one was the
like four years ago i wish i had it
still some guy some guy some kid bought
a bunch of our clothes and the dad hit
us up like hey my son is 16 years old he
could not be wearing this even though i
think your designs are great and that's
a beautiful shirt
that he's a beautiful shirt oh this
guy's great i cannot have my underage
son wearing and promoting marijuana
clothing i hope you understand i'm like
you know what sir yes and i'll pay for
the shipping don't even worry about it
you're cool bro because if not the best
part is when the parents get pissed like
you guys are pieces [ __ ] [ __ ] telling
kids to smoke weed you're [ __ ] pieces
of [ __ ]
oh by the way i bet you you pay for the
shipping and i'm not going to refund you
until i get the clothes and they're fine
like all companies do but they get so
mad he gets so bad like i'm paying
bishop yeah
i'm not paying for it
and they get so mad anyway
so
that's just some of the stuff anyway
i've got a lot of people
just being jerks
um
you guys got to remember
i i think a lot of people that say
stupid [ __ ] to me like i'm a piece of
[ __ ] have never watched anything i've
ever done
i think they i think they heard that
that guy thomas said something offensive
well i'm gonna go [ __ ] on him
i think that's what it is because a lot
of the people come at me guys i know i
sound like i'm just chilling i'm not
dumb i'm a very smart person i know i
don't know politics because i don't give
a [ __ ] about stress in my life i don't
watch news that often because all of
it's like another kid got shot today i'm
like
i'm gonna watch all this guys
i'm a smart person in terms of
common sense
all right
i've been calling people dumb [ __ ]
since i was four if you're a dumb [ __ ]
i can see it whether you're 40 or not
you're still a dumb [ __ ]
there's a and you can be a guy and still
be a dumb [ __ ] too all right
[ __ ] let's call saying girls are
[ __ ] that's not what i'm saying
so when it comes to these topics
i have thoughts in my brain and if i
don't like how i said it i go you know
what let me rephrase that i don't like
that i've said that many times you know
let me say it better than that that was
[ __ ] stupid
because i know consequences of things
also i'm not a piece of [ __ ] when the
camera's off or at heart
so if i'm a big one that's the biggest
bar like i'm not like yo can we cut that
out i just said something racist
and i meant the [ __ ] out no i've never
done that i'm like yo you might get in
trouble with that because it's funny
you get in trouble for [ __ ] comedy
and offensive [ __ ] i get it
i like that [ __ ] i like the anthony
jeselnik style of comedy i love daniel
tosh style of comedy because it made me
go
oh my god fool you're a dick but that
was so funny if you can stand there and
go
oh i said that that's what i said
then i like you
you know if you could stand by what you
said for sure because there's a lot of
things you you i tell you like i can't
say that bro i can't say that because i
first off i don't believe that but it's
still [ __ ]
funny as [ __ ]
but
i get it how people can get mad about it
but there's a lot of things i think are
very funny that are [ __ ] up
so
you don't have to watch it there's
horror movies
there's gore movies
nobody's saying you're promoting murder
but they probably are don't [ __ ]
watch it my kid's gonna grow up crazy
because your kid's a [ __ ] creep
that's it there's nothing different
bobby boucher's mom
think about that all right
look how he was raised very strict still
nice guy he's not out there killing
[ __ ] hey
that's probably a bad example
i don't care everything is that i had a
sailor loop back all right
that's how today's gonna end i'm just
gonna
all right
so one time i was a billionaire right
and my dad was giving this company this
guy i didn't like
and i was like but dad what if i go back
to school finish every grade redo it in
two weeks graduate and then i get the
company
well billy
sorry
sorry guys that's what i'm gonna do
everywhere every time someone asks me
what's your order number sir so when i
was a kid and i was gonna go into a
different movie i was a talking dog and
i had another dog friend and a cat and
our family went out of town and we were
like yo
we gotta find them and at home we're
bound to
i don't know i'm just gonna start saying
this
the [ __ ] in the back right has a fake
laugh
i can hear it
i don't like her fake laugh sorry guys
we're just talking [ __ ] out here what
time are we at
120 120. so um
to sum it up what i should really say is
if i ever say something that offends you
remember don't waste your time
to comment
go make a forum
go get me canceled or something do
something productive
don't waste the time with the comment
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna type back
okay
because that makes people really mad
when they type a paragraph of what
they're mad about and type back okay
it's the best and i love it
all right so to remember i don't give a
[ __ ]
at all i don't care about your opinion
even a slight bit if it's coming at me
as you shouldn't have said that
that's what i'm saying i don't care
about your opinion fan or not if you
don't like it don't watch it
that's what i'm trying to say
and it's not like i'm sitting here going
uh [ __ ] this and [ __ ] that i'm not
being a piece of [ __ ] i'm trying to
figure out the [ __ ] you're even
referring to
all right oh there's just i go through
all the comments marty yeah
so i've gotten like
dude all right 99.9
is our average rating of thumbs ups in
the back end point one percent is thumbs
down yeah which is unfucking believable
right it might even be less it just
don't have that fraction to show that
there's a little bit there's the less
than there's a less than yes
so when i see i go through all the
comments so it's like
i know you're like don't think about the
naked it's not the negative it's the
is that anything we're saying that's
what it's like do you think me and marty
are bigots that's what's like you must
have not watched the show
there's no way you watch the show and
thought that unless you're a [ __ ]
idiot i think some people are just are
stupid yeah because when i said hey
comedy's funny when i talked about david
bell [ __ ] there was so many people
talking [ __ ] to me on that oh i didn't
see any of this i go i have to i do all
the comments i'm just like
shut the [ __ ] up
i don't care
i don't care at all
shut up it's my opinion if you're just
being shitty because a lot of times when
people are being shitty in the comments
if you go
once twice three times back and forth
with them there's nothing there and
they're like
i'm just like i was just talking [ __ ]
basically like yeah sorry i'm sorry okay
yeah good job i don't know that's i mean
there's there's no way especially when
we the more we have on more and more and
more guests yeah it's controversial
guess that like i know people are going
to be mad i would love to talk to alex
jones that'd be [ __ ] amazing wild as
[ __ ] i want to go
what's on your what's on your mind today
i just want to go oh go for it bro yeah
i just want to hear the [ __ ] you got
you're like of science fiction we can't
judge our guests that harshly either
like i mean fiction sorry you know like
we can't we're going to have on who the
fans want to see and who's going to be
interesting and interesting people or if
we think it's going to be amazing
conversation we want to introduce new
people to the world
we can't you know vowed for we had the
biggest drug dealer in the world on the
[ __ ] show he was great or dude i had
a bunch of people like you have stevo on
he had a baby [ __ ] tattoo on his arm
he's a pedophile
what did you and you're a piece of [ __ ]
for supporting i go
stop what you just said ho
and go watch his documentary on why he
got that he had a tattoo of a guy
[ __ ] a baby oh jesus christ and it's
like whoa
and i saw the documentary he goes i was
just like kat von d and we were [ __ ]
up we're like yo i never want kids she
was like [ __ ] babies no babies and she's
like i would tap that to tattoo [ __ ]
big having babies so what if we went
like babies with a cross with a circle
like [ __ ] no no babies like what about a
word that said [ __ ] baby
and he's like what if it was a guy
[ __ ] a baby he's like oh [ __ ] face
four in the morning and i got a guy even
the tattoo was like what the [ __ ] and he
goes i thought it was so it's [ __ ]
funny right he's like walk outside some
fans are like oh [ __ ] stevo and he goes
look what i just got he goes the looks
on their faces told me i should have
never got this [ __ ] tattoo he said
when i sobered up i go bro did you
really get a baby [ __ ] tattoo what's
wrong with you so now it's like a guy
[ __ ] an ostrich
god
but things like that yeah people hear
one thing go oh he [ __ ] kids we would
have no guests if you [ __ ] do that to
everybody but that's a little extra dude
there's a thing about me that got i
don't think i've ever told you
one time on instagram in like 2013 i got
cancelled did i tell you this no
i'm gonna talk about it
i love it so much
one time
this girl this influencer [ __ ]
uh
and i'm not saying all girls are [ __ ] i
have to always explain that cause me and
rosie always say that oh that one [ __ ]
rosie says it so much that it's like
it's a second nature it's like dude for
girl for me sometimes sometimes when
they're dumb as [ __ ] and it pisses me
off by this girl that we hung out with
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] pissed me off
that's you see what i'm saying this
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh this dude i met
levels of being pissed
anyway this [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
i said something i posted something and
then she
commented this before dm she commented
something kind of like ew why would you
say that's kind of mean [ __ ] you and i
wrote back like okay dick
i know this is relevant but it's really
funny i promise you it's so [ __ ]
funny to me
are you ready
so i'm going along and i'm like going
back and forth or i'm like damn i
remember where i was standing in my push
trees houses that long ago i'm standing
there i'm like controversy i've
everyone's always so nice online i've
never like gotten back and forth with
people like this
and i'm talking to her like do you
what
and then she starts talking [ __ ] as a
pregnant woman and a cannabis this and
that and i'm like
what [ __ ]
and i started talking i she pissed me
off when i went
you ever seen knocked up the movie
knocked up with seth rogen
okay hold on if you haven't for everyone
out there that knows the movie quotable
if you've seen it enough
remember when craig robinson is the
bouncer at the [ __ ]
maybe when craig robinson is the bouncer
at the nightclub
and that when she's pregnant and she
brings her sister and the sisters older
she's like dank in this nightclub i feel
kind of old and the other girl's
pregnant and he walks up and goes and
craig robin's like i can't be having
little old ladies and pregnant [ __ ]
up in here what the [ __ ] man
that's funny that line of that movie was
[ __ ] up but he's like but i would
[Laughter]
stop that
don't do that to me
bro what are you doing why did you have
that that was so creepy but perfect
i could barely hear it at first that
[ __ ] is creepy because i was thinking
about the scene like
am i thinking of seth robin's laugh in
my head i'm just out here spitting on
[ __ ]
bro marty loves it look at his face look
at his face he loves that that's the
best
that [ __ ] goes for like 10 minutes does
it oh yeah it does get shorter
yo i'm sorry i'm sorry
anyway i'm going back and forth this
girl online
and i quote that entire movie scene
because she was a pregnant [ __ ] and
she's over here trying to [ __ ] as a
person that does this and this i think
you're offensive for saying and i was
just talking [ __ ] because i'm an [ __ ]
because i said the lion as a dick
because it's funny so anybody that reads
it's like
yo
this could have been better because
we're going back and forth like and i
was like you're pregnant you probably
shouldn't be out doing this right now
anyway you're nine months pregnant isn't
that [ __ ] dangerous to be out here
taking [ __ ] dabs at the events and
going out in the sun and the hot sun
[ __ ]
go dab at home
or don't dab at all once you're smoking
weed like that very heavily once you're
pregnant it's almost beneficial to not
stop damn and slow down because it's
like a vitamin in your body
controversial topic go look it up on
[ __ ] google and from experience of
how many girls i know have had babies
that smoke mass amounts of weed
they just slow down like times 90 and
this we did medicate very softly
for nausea
and for the fact that you're literally
just stopping smoking weed when your
body's
you got to remember the people i chill
with smoke weed 55 times a day it's not
like oh i smoke on the weekend it's
nothing like that i'm not saying that's
a cool reference i'm saying
how heavily your body's relying on like
okay cool kind of annoying to me okay
cool this one's in okay cbd oh t-shirts
oh this you know i mean that's what i'm
saying anyway i quoted that whole thing
because
because she was talking about being out
i'm like [ __ ] you're pregnant you oh go
in the [ __ ] house what's wrong with
and i quoted the whole thing
bro
i didn't realize that people don't know
what quotation marks are
these people thought i was calling her
pregnant [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] ass in the house
it was a [ __ ] quote
but it was
perfect for what i was saying like
[ __ ] you oh she's pregnant that's
exactly what i was being it was craig
robinson quote you should have made it
into a meme i got cancelled real quick
but not for real uh some people got mad
and i don't give a [ __ ] and uh a bunch
of people like a grip a circle of these
[ __ ] women uh-huh we're like this
guy's a [ __ ] sexist
like
so
it's not true do you know the definition
of sexism
i'm actually the cable guy man you need
to [ __ ] yeah you actually need to go
watch knocked up because it's a really
really really good scene it's about
women empowerment going out whether
you're old or pregnant [ __ ]
that's what the scene's about but they
get [ __ ] on because she's pregnant
anyway i got in a lot of trouble i guess
so what i'm trying to say is even though
there was a group of people and they
made a page about me not talk to all the
sponsors everybody i ever worked with
everything
everything
i don't care
i forgot about it until we brought this
up so you know
um but there's a lot of people lately
marty that have been in the comments
just going hard on me and you got to
remember guys no one cares nobody cares
i don't first off
don't give a [ __ ]
if i say something offensive and i
realize that i'm wrong
i will apologize and i've done that
before
when the
some kind of [ __ ]
with the riots
and someone said something i was like
that's dumb
and then they're like everybody attacked
me for it and then they said it in the
intellectual way that they should have
said and not the badgering way i went i
can kind of see what you mean on how you
can say that would help
i apologize and i said sorry but i was
like i still think the way i think but i
see from your side 100
more now that i get what you're saying
so i will apologize if i feel like i'm
wrong of course and i'm going to look at
it logically it's a yes or no answer
it's not like well i i think no it's not
i think it's like am i
am i wrong
yeah
i'm not all like super opinionated like
that i'm really easy i'm always like i'm
able to be
yeah i like when i was telling like man
[ __ ] white people mari's
[ __ ] making white grapes out here
[Laughter]
that was my favorite part [ __ ] white
grapes
marty you're such a fool
that was my favorite part of the show
oh my god oh sorry sorry i didn't see
that one coming yeah not at all let's
wrap it all up that's that that quote or
that grip i wanted to talk about is
like i said on that show if you knew how
little i cared you'd be offended but
also you do care it's just when people
are being shitty
it's if my statement had nothing to do
with
being a bigot yeah if you i mean jesus
christ if you can't understand a joke
yeah yeah a a joke
if i ever do this after i say something
just know that even i know
dale yeah
[ __ ]
but
come on
[ __ ] eat a dick or don't watch
there's a lot more podcasts you can go
look at
it's not like we're offensive
we don't 50 first date rapes was funny
no doubt about that that's funny yeah
that's the one i thought you were gonna
get mad about no nobody got mad
everybody just went you're right i know
and i was talking about there's so many
movies bro oh sorry before before i go i
got to say one of the funniest things
i've ever seen in my entire life
happened the other day i was going to
get food i stopped put money in the
meter
and i look on the side of the meter
and someone in white marker wrote the
irishman
just like the title of the movie the
irishman
some [ __ ] amazing person
that i need to be friends with
got a black marker
and cross the irishman now i'm not
saying the irish is a bad movie
crossed it out and put was a shitty
movie dot dot dot somebody put their
[ __ ] movie review on the side of a
tagging
as a tagging
inspired me
i want to start leaving movie reviews as
taggings
right there grandpa joe from willy wonka
couldn't walk didn't help free trip to
candy store got right up piece of [ __ ]
but good movie
just little little quotes like maybe a
sticker
and i stick them up like
forrest gump you're gonna say mom took
one for the team yeah jenny was a [ __ ]
jenny was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
hate her so much
hate her violently how did he not get
aids too
you're probably just he was just strong
he fought through that he was just
strong
he flexed it out forest could flex aids
off him
randy hates she had aids came back and
had a baby with him
this [ __ ]
early thought is going on with [ __ ]
jenny
jenny was a ho i'm sorry i ruined
y'all's black panther party
i said that where did that whose party
knife i [ __ ] something up one time and
i said that out loud when you drove
through the set
[Laughter]
thank you
so much i ruined y'all's black panther
party i'm so sorry guys this whole
episode i don't have a topic you know
what's gonna be called oh [ __ ]
what were we talking about yeah that's
the name of the episode oh [ __ ] this is
just the ketchup this is just like
catching up guys there was no stories in
this one i didn't want to throw any
stories out in this one i want to
start switching up the solo episodes the
first episode of the season was very
uh
segment segmenty you know i'm saying
like there was like three of them yeah
this one was more of us just talking
[ __ ] talking about stuff that's going on
i can't believe it's in the morning
right now mm-hmm i went to bed at like
four damn i don't know how you do that
probably why i'm like
i feel all off just make that [ __ ]
bomb ass joint though
um yes guys so basically what's going on
push trees drop just did a whole new
drop hats be oh beanies hats
everything's out new rigs are out
um
marty cleaned up all the clients so
marty's life is back on track well
on track we're about to be on track so
i'm saying like first times of you
having to be like oh god i got 12 jobs
like even as i just sit here it's like
weird huh it feels like so much weight
just lifted off my shoulders
and i just want to get after it through
the podcast you know
you know just bigger and better [ __ ]
yeah we also want to do something uh
whether it's a live
all right look it
you know like reaction videos i think
it'd be really we're talking about it'd
be really cool if me and marty were
sitting right here
camera on us we're doing a reaction i
show marty some music videos marty shows
me some music videos i show marty some
this i show marty this just every week
just doing some type of like marty and i
do this
marty and i react to this
this week you gotta be like you put me
on to so much [ __ ] i didn't really
realize like i don't know that's what i
was saying i want to play a certain
music video though have already ever
seen this
play some crazy [ __ ] i think that'd be
fun and it's a way of everybody else
learning about new music and [ __ ]
because they always say you drop hell of
references like
well let's talk about the movies today
and i want to do
my version of movie
do you know where we could uh very
easily do this without having any
issues worried about copyrighted flags
or anything like that site
or even
our own [ __ ] app
oh
oh
did we make one for which cash two well
it's gonna fall under it's gonna fall
into the same app okay true i normally
don't talk about [ __ ] like this early
before it happens but but you already
started it yeah that's i'm an official
apple google developer now i don't know
how to [ __ ] code anything dopa's yola
app is now real well it's about to be
some i don't know i've never done this
before i don't know how long it's going
to take but
we're it's built like it's processing
that [ __ ] is going to be in the app
stores at some point in the near future
oh
so you watch all our [ __ ] by clicking
going through your app uh story times
push notifications push notifications
live comments likes all that the
functionalities of the site through an
app
there will be no more missing the
notifications if you're exactly there is
no more missing notifications push
notifications from a [ __ ] store or
app in the store yeah
for whatever you drop like you might be
dropping a push trees drop you might be
dropping some exclusive [ __ ] to the
people on the app yeah whatever what i
want to do
one thing we talked about before i would
like to feature
other content creators
pictures picture of the week
whoa i found this [ __ ] dude doing
videos
go check his [ __ ] out even though it's
not even weed it could be anything yeah
of course just something to help us go
here's the people we've been seeing do
cool [ __ ]
hopefully this helps them out
because we have a big platform it'd be
cool to go like bam bam bam bam you
understand like that's kind of tight you
know to be able to help you what i mean
accessing [ __ ] that we like
not just like pushing dumb skits and
here's a guy promoting beets
i'm not saying beets are dumb i'm saying
like do you know what i'm saying like
it's stupid
this [ __ ]
stuff you guys know what i'm talking
about memes no memes yep all right
unless you're making them if somebody's
making their own memes i'm all with it
because that takes a long time to think
of funny [ __ ] it really does i used to
do it and it's it sticks a lot art takes
a while yeah it takes a minute um so
that's pretty much everything i want to
talk about there is this rapper i
never heard of the rapper sorry
but my brother has his name is kashi
dami kashi
dom i don't know he's got a song with
trippy red
and in the song the very beginning he's
talking about [ __ ] me which is very
cool shout out to you for dropping that
little shout out in your song i've
gotten hundreds of dms about it
non-stop people like yo have you seen
that this full shout out you out the
song which should be read like oh
cool when i listened to it and i was
like
oh he did
it really is my name i thought they were
like oh no you're miss you're mishearing
so shout out to you for that it's pretty
[ __ ] awesome thank you very much uh
cool
pretty sick it's like a smoking line so
i was like oh perfect it's tight
um
but yeah that was pretty much everything
that's been going on the past couple
weeks i've just been so [ __ ] busy man
every day just
just so busy even my mom and my brother
are here
every day and justin's been here for 12
13 days and we've been filming doing
something every [ __ ] day almost
it's
just [ __ ] this is weird recording
before the premiere of the next episode
i know as soon as this is done i'm gonna
get ready for the premiere or the be
real episode
back to the future [ __ ] going on right
now it's cool though
i like it dude it's sucking i feel
ahead
the first time i feel like i need to go
do those tick tock videos with a guy
this is what i do i make my bed at 5 30
and i'm making tea 501 at 502 i'm
[ __ ] yeah i [ __ ] i'm at the gym
at 504 yeah right [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
uh but you probably are
that's how i feel my life needs to be i
want my life to look like an apple store
i wake up and everything's in place and
i'm sorry
but rosie is not as tidy as me
rosie's a girl like you know when girls
get ready in the bathroom they just go
explosion yeah that's pretty much what
our bathroom is every time but she she
she's always cleaning [ __ ] too with me
that's what i need our house to be i
can't live in this apartment no more i'm
getting this house in march i'm [ __ ]
over it and uh i'm excited so things are
changing things are gonna be cool
everything's going awesome
super [ __ ] excited i finally picked
out the rims
i would tell you guys
i finally got the i tell you what
happened to the rims
oh you got these i went packed all these
rims with studio motors and as we leave
and i'm like how much of the razor goes
it could be more than 12k
[ __ ] threw up inside outside i went
oh
but inside oh man no
i don't want to do it and you know don't
worry bro i'll get it way way cheaper
that wholesale
still
anyway i was going to do it i'm like i
don't care [ __ ] it i [ __ ] been doing
so much [ __ ] that's the most money i
ever spent on myself
ever times a million
[ __ ] it
and then he goes how's the weight he's
like it takes about 12 weeks to make him
i went
let's reevaluate this and then i found
other rims that are already because
they're three piece rims and they have
to be made they're forged or whatever
nah i'm good either so badass i should
have ordered him along i just don't want
to wait three more months to get my car
done
you know what i'm saying i want it to be
done there's got to be rims i found some
yeah almost
a third of the price um
very very cool
goddamn i remember one time i was
changing the tire on my impala
i had nepal like in 2005 impala when i
was working at maintenance i went to go
change the tire and i remember looking
at the rams like ah ribs are cool that's
cool i'm looking at the ransom like
400 dollars a rim
[ __ ] you sears that's why you're out of
business today number said
like 400 that's the most ex i'm like man
i did the math like you want someone to
pay
1600 dollars for ribs
preposterous
and then i walked out of there going
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
this this is some [ __ ]
but now that i'm thinking like now that
i realized
first off thank you guys for supporting
everything and allowing me to go and
make a decision like that
thank you for real because we worked for
free for so long and for me to finally
like i said i tweeted the other day i
went to the grocery store the other day
and i didn't check the price i just paid
for my [ __ ] left
never have i done that in my life and if
you grew up kind of poor you know that's
not real that doesn't happen your cat
you're poor when you're
counting up everything in your head as
you're going up to the cash where it's
like
four dollars two dollars
you're paying with receipts from the
coin star
paying with receipts from the coins what
do you mean
because you just returned returned a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ] coins i've done that
all the time yeah that's a given that's
a giveaway no that's a good i'm talking
about like when you're kidding like oh
[ __ ] how much money do we get
there's 37 with this [ __ ] in that basket
do we even have 37 dollars worth of [ __ ]
you know what i mean like counting up
everything like oh i'm gonna put that
back
it's so weird because that's how i feel
with everything until
i realized my friend told me was like
dude do you want to get old and never
spent any of the money you made as a kid
you know so you're only gonna make young
ones
[ __ ] you you're right damn it and that's
why i bought the car
only reason in the world i bought that
car so you're [ __ ] right
and then i've been working so long so
hard for so many for
a decade now
for never making any money until last
year it's like you know what [ __ ] it so
that's why when i came out going wow i
remember when i thought sixteen hundred
dollars for rims these rims are four
apiece
or three thousand a piece
and i just bought them in my head and
then i found out i don't know 12 weeks
what do you think you kidnapped chelsea
clinton
i just watched rush hour too and then uh
which one y'all kicked me
that's how i felt when he's like 12 man
i kicked in the face like chris tucker
and uh
anyway thank you guys so much for
supporting everything and push trees and
[ __ ] and allowing me to even make a
decision to go yeah i'll spend that
[ __ ] insane because i've been pouring
my whole [ __ ] life forever so for it
to finally not be so [ __ ] is crazy
thank you
so much i feel about the house bro
that's different when i walked in like
whoa
you have a house house now oh [ __ ] your
stairs are so wide it's only because of
the podcast it really is why are the
stairs so wide you could take a bet
[ __ ] you could sideways down there i
felt fancy with the wide [ __ ] stairs
i'm sure it was nice it was like a
[ __ ] wait till your kids go to prom
and you're like yep those are the stairs
you've seen you know movies right there
that's how i felt seeing your stairs
but yeah that would you say that how's
that podcasting built yeah it really is
it really is each man the [ __ ] if the
podcast was not going the show would not
have gone well
[ __ ] it's crazy
it's crazy
we'll be open we're always transparent
when me and marty finally started making
money in the podcast how weird was it we
went
we made money today on this episode
yeah
whoa
that was just like motivation right
that was just yeah i like oh i know we
can really do this [ __ ] like this is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this is real this is a
long-term thing here it's special yeah
dude it's very uh
very cool guys it's just me and mario
one day we will have a team we need to
have more people we're good guys sitting
here with bts i would love i love this
set love it we'll be here for a while i
would love to get our own building for
the podcast just our own [ __ ] space
this is great we can be in the warehouse
forever
i would love our own space we don't
we're not really boxing it as crazy as
we thought we would like what if we have
you know smoke two zips but you can't
smoke two zips and conversate with a
person a regular doesn't work
they're done
so our it's not like we'll ever be like
crazy boxing two zips
in a [ __ ] joint
it doesn't work like that you can't
conversate so we could get our own
building party and just get a [ __ ]
air purifier and a [ __ ]
uh vet
like to do with the grows but at the
front door and smoke our building out
what we want
i don't know
just
things to think about thank you guys for
making it possible
for real thank you so much
uh yeah
hell yeah pretty cool
this [ __ ] is crazy
yes and do me do us a favor guys
there's a
there's
what
like 50 new clips on the clips channel
they're going home the clips dope as
usual podcast clips go watch the clips
channel marty's been doing so many
[ __ ] clips
there's so much [ __ ] for people that
can't watch the full podcast and you
just go watch the clips channel
it's there and we're finally doing good
on the clips channel so thank you guys
so much for making that possible that is
unbelievable and an added bonus and it
supports the podcast too i noticed the
numbers for certain episodes grow
whenever we drop clips
yeah yeah just funnels no doubt about it
so yeah thank you guys thank you apparel
is coming up mari's house is almost done
uh i'm kind of high how long we've been
here hour
mm-hmm we're on there all right cool you
did good guys thank you so much for
being here this was not uh
kicked out another run the college
episode this is not that type of episode
this is the catch-up episode hanging out
with your friends episode hi hello how
you doing
[Laughter]
so uh
i think it's everything man yeah yeah
listen you're talking
it's a good day [ __ ] yeah also
wearing a beanie
where the [ __ ] beanie that's girl if
you guys remember when i first started
instagram i just put a bd on one day and
took a picture
and then it became like
the bart simpson orange shirt
fools were like where's your beanie at
when i would post a picture without it
and i would look at the picture like
something's missing
i wore that beanie for six years
every picture
because there's just part of it mm-hmm
even though i wasn't wearing a beating
that day i go oh hold on look at that
picture it's like oh gee with this class
no i need my glasses on it's like that
no i can't put my hand up bro
you know what i mean like i don't know i
just became part of
people who liked it online like now i'll
just keep the aesthetic right even my
first stickers and designs had me with
my beanie on uh-huh and then i lost that
[ __ ] drunk
i don't remember where obviously if i
did i'd find it i don't remember where i
lost it it's just been gone forever so i
haven't worn a beanie for [ __ ] three
years that's so for you it was the
beanie it wasn't just wearing a beanie
it was my one being i always were i was
saying fitteds and [ __ ] since i was a
[ __ ] yeah i don't really wear hats
i don't really wear hats or beanies this
is the first
one one particular one so when i ever
only ever rocked ever i bought it so
fresh clothing in santa cruz california
i bought it so fresh
and i didn't wear it for two years just
bought it and i put it on one day i like
beanies huh and i wore it i was 22 until
i was like 27
28 and i lost it
so here's beanies again
it's weird it makes me feel like
old dobasiola videos getting high
dabbing bho on titan yeah
what's up shirts are sick though yeah
i'll [ __ ] with them i [ __ ] with them uh
guys thank you so much for being here
appreciate it we just been talking [ __ ]
so
thanks
all right don't drink and drive
please
morally episode don't drink and drive
don't be a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
don't waste your time commenting if
you're offended because nobody cares
except for you
and my last line
dope's usual podcast it's not for
everyone uh yeah let's go yep my dad was
here yesterday and i told him we used
his his uh line for his little slogan
uh-huh oh really oh yeah dad
that was it
oh really huh
i thought you were a laugh about it or
something
damn it how about that how about that
all right [ __ ] yeah no it was genius it
was smart good [ __ ] it was perfect oh
it's like all right
get out of here my grandma was here
yesterday it was so odd um grandma in
the warehouse she was in here wow it was
so weird when you just told that you
smoke weed too not that long ago the way
i told that what i do for yeah yeah
um my little brother sisters everybody
was here is weird
so odd habitable how's that built and
[ __ ]
and not them yeah which is the best part
right now i didn't ask you guys for [ __ ]
yeah
tour my facilities yeah it's awesome
dude it's really cool especially with
the
you guys haven't seen it but the
warehouse is like a warehouse now since
we're in here uh-huh like push more
shelves there's more [ __ ] we got the
big-ass rollers we got all like the
stuff to make it a full warehouse for
every kid going through [ __ ] with their
parents over weed right now that is so
like true i don't know if inspirational
is a word for it everything but i like
that man
i've been saying like i never think
about like
what i must look like to the average
person i never think because it's just
what i'm doing yeah it's like uh yeah i
get high on the internet
but did you interview someone so
i did i did
i always think about like oh yeah that's
right not like i forgot
but more like i never think about oh
[ __ ] that was i'm sick never happened
right you know i'm saying that it's more
of like that [ __ ] was tight
also i'm [ __ ] busy
i gotta go do this
um so a real quick last night remember i
told you i found all my pictures marty i
used to make so many pictures and it
reminded me it almost made me feel like
sad that i don't do it anymore but i
have to remember that's when i would
just had 12 hours a day and not doing
[ __ ] and i was just smoking as much as i
could yeah
but i found so many funny pictures of my
old photo albums guys i found all my
notes from 2015.
i'm so offensive
i'm so [ __ ] offensive bad
bad but in the best way to me because
it's funny
i found a lot of stuff when i was trying
to do stand-up [ __ ] when i was trying to
write almost and i found a lot of my
[ __ ] last night
wow
wow
[ __ ]
my first stand-up show i'm gonna come
out and the first line i'm gonna say
he's gonna make the cradle
i hope you're my fans in the ground up
that's not just some open mic night i
might get jumped
uh i'll be dressed i'll try i'm just
kidding
thomas said you'll beat everyone's ass i
won't i'm very nice barney will beat
your ass already sent me a picture with
the screw
bar you found the old screw that we
talked about the story put it up on you
oh yeah somebody
you know you know the other day
all right still cracking sorry what time
we got 148
yeah 150. oh all right we did cool yeah
yeah cool the last 20 30 minutes
chill
guys this is probably the only episode
of the season like this
we're not going to be doing rant cds as
much anymore which i know it's cool but
i need to
just chair some screening i need to be
on
topic more
that's what i feel yeah so rant city
maybe we'll even say like next week
chill episode just i feel like we had
one like catch-up episode last
season i forget which one it was
yeah if we go on a stretch of guests we
gotta [ __ ] just this is what we
haven't done if we have so many guests
in a row we gotta just come out and hang
out
because i like i said i can't
just do dumb
they're rather other people while i'm
interviewing like you know i mean a
guest coming out i don't know this guy
like his podcast and this other guy they
get high but all right and i get there
hey
one time i was a soldier in oregon this
cop wouldn't let me
that's kind of like where it comes you
ever see that always sunny when danny
devito thinks he lives the life of rambo
but is actually just rambo first blood
but he keeps telling everybody that but
he believes that that's really his life
that is kind of like what i'm doing
right now yeah with the story steve
might not have got that yeah
yeah if i started telling steve all like
yo me and my brother my brother's
handicap and my mom she's really
morbidly obese we can't get it out of
the house
is that what city gilbert grape but it
is it is what's in the gilbert grape
good job stevo see that we don't do that
we can't do that stuff but i can do it
to you guys
cause we know each other
we know each other so it's okay all
right i'm done i'm done i'm done i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm done guys thank you
so much for watching this [ __ ]
podcast this has been the dopes usual
podcast i am dopaziolo this is marty
o'neill hold it wait for it wait for it
[Music]
go go stop oh my god
that [ __ ] is longer than the goddamn
south rogan is it oh that's not the
record goes on for [ __ ] ever oh my
god you need to get just the pop-up boom
your first time on acid okay if we just
get those going
[Laughter]
oh this horror gets closer
that's the shot i'm thinking
very [ __ ] clockwork
exactly
the funnest laugh just turned scary over
[ __ ] 10 minutes
cause you're like why is it true no not
stop
we're trying to end the show
all right i'm gonna say that right now
this is the first time i ended it
cleanly i've already kept it all right
guys all right not my fault this time
please be safe driving please be careful
driving uh look over your shoulder uh
cops coming for somebody that's smoking
in the park
sit on the bench on top of the table so
you can see [ __ ] coming stop
sitting with your legs under the bench
because that's how you get jumped
just a little piece of information i
don't know why i said that just in case
you're actually watching this at the
park be safe um there's no reason for
that but it's true
never put your legs under yeah guys have
a dope ass day i'm gonna go finish my
monday oh no b-roll episode comes out
right now
thanks guys thanks for being here thanks
for hanging out this has been the dope
as usual podcast have a dope ass day
yo
i could have been 10 minutes long i
couldn't tell you what we talked about i
feel so [ __ ] lost
why
[Music]
pretty blurry
yeah
yeah i couldn't tell you what we talked
about man
oh [ __ ] what's he had me today
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect